quite a debut for Shane Irving his pics
last week so Iowa State was a push plus
three South Alabama did not cover TCU -
three covered Oklahoma plus seven and a
half I knew you were big on that they
covered outright and Pitt plus 21 and a
half covered so three one and one for
the debut as we bring up some Johnny
Cash the theme music for the man in
black
Shane Irving joining us here in the man
cave well done first week there Shea
yeah every squirrel finds a nut every
now and then you made some money I made
a couple bucks it didn't work out as
well Iowa State should have won outright
that was awful I was listening that game
in the core driving the roommate and the
kids cross-country while they're
screaming at me about the iPad not
working or whatnot and I've got it
turned up to 11 because that game was so
close they should have won outright
Danny where were you driving from her to
she caught from Chicago to Fairfield
County yeah it was miserable Danny when
we hit New Jersey they had a revolution
in the back seat they were having no
more doesn't it oh they hate me hated me
more in that vehicle all right well the
betters love you after what you did your
debut week now once again entertainment
purposes only so your picks this week
are put the mortgage on it Tulsa plus
eight and a half messy State plus seven
and a half
Wyoming plus fourteen Mizzou minus seven
Michigan minus twenty-three and a half
SMU plus nineteen and a half and IU plus
fourteen here's my problem I win one
week and I think I'm a professional and
I just add the whole cord everything
yeah do you have a big play of the week
is Tulsa your no Tulsa no Tulsa is not
heavy okay I'm heavy on Wyoming close 14
gets organ okay Oregon coming off an
impressive first half if not a second
half awful second half yes
Nebraska covered that game yeah in that
remarkable unbelievable it was 42 what
42 17 or something crazy so stupid
Paulie had a five-star pick he wanted to
run by now no NFL picks you I got NFL
picks right now oh you do okay
okay Vikings +5 and a half at Pittsburgh
giant sling blade - three against
Stafford
fairly plus five and a half against
Chiefs at Casey
mmm-hmm does anybody does Philly win
outright yeah I feel like Anne went out
right Alex mitt can't throw the ball 35
yards we kind of did that against they
did it once okay it took 15 minutes to
get there
I think sling blades gonna have a
comeback coz old Odell is gonna get off
of his emotional handicap and be back in
the game probably yeah I think where the
consensus is Odell Beckham plays in this
game I know he said it's a six to eight
week injury I think he's sort of using
that as a tank it's emotional he's just
emotionally disturbed he had to go see
his therapist or something I was crying
about something else is that where he
went to the club and he was having his
dance-off with absolutely all right
Paulie your 5-star special my army Black
Knights are getting 30 when I tell you
che and I owe State but here's the play
no army first-half getting 18 and a half
points it's a good take Ohio State a
little time know to figure out the army
offense just like it happened a couple
years ago that took a while to figure
out Navy Ohio State wins but army with a
big first half to allow state cover you
say first half army army covers the 18
and a half first half points at Ohio
State covers the whole game I'm not
touching the whole game I'm touching the
first half for Army I'll take that I'll
book that action right now with you how
much I'll put i'll put 50 on army to
cover
make it a hundred you got a bit I'm
doing 50 I snake but I believe borrow
money from somebody next to you make it
a hundred
you got a bet I'll throw in the other
there we go I was gonna do wheel of
punishment
she would've shot wheel of punishment
for che I didn't take che for
anti-american betting again my country
my brother actually went there believe
it or not to West Point oh yeah he went
to West Point like he drove there was
thought that was it was a steep decline
from him to me but it happened yeah he
went to West Point he's a veteran so go
to Hill about hating America oh wow okay
so go right to hell so it's Army's
getting 18 and a half they ain't
covering first half points ain't
happening okay so front row has got for
a Hyundai a beam that's right a beam
okay B don't make me come looking for
either when it happens oh here we go
next week I'll come in here with pennies
pennies I'll come here with a jar
if I lose that bit how about how about
the shower of shame with pennies 100
pennies dropped on your head I think
it's more than hundred yeah I'm sorry
yeah my bad I was told there'd be no
math on this program my back so that's
it those are the bets
no no parlays no nothing no teasers no
but I will tell you a secret
okay just me and you talking hi alright
I'm in a teaser League Oh hundred dudes
yeah ten bucks a bet yeah you got to
pick a 1414 Timur right fourteen
fourteen points everybody that wins is
owed ten bucks by everybody that loses
there's 100 news there's a thousand
bucks in the line every week so if
you're the only winner you get 990
you're going to lose are you oh nine
ninety I just heard about this three
years ago I can't stop Danny it's all I
do it's amazing it's that addicting it's
a perfect thing perfect but you have a
day job and you have a wife and you have
a roommate right roommate - kids yeah
but are you married
yeah we're I mean well you are man
really yeah when we live together Danny
I don't want to denigrate a lot of folks
are married don't live together
I live with my roommate yes is she a
common-law wife she's that and it's on
it's legal binding contract control yeah
yeah I told her I just can't imagine you
with kids diapers yeah that doesn't I
don't you don't diaper I'm not allowed
to Danny I messed it up so bad the first
time I did it did you do it on purpose
by design just like just like the dishes
I broke everyone glass and a dishwasher
and the first diaper I had ended up on
the floor contains and all okay so recap
your picks here for a week - I just
dropped my sheet all right
Tulsa plus eight and a half SMU plus
nineteen and a half Oregon plus fourteen
no no no I only closed 14 against the
worgen um you can pick up the sheet I
don't want to show my face well nobody
hold on oh you got to get the Sheep
Danny I had a couple beers before I got
here you can smell it yes well you got
awful beer in here it was warm it's been
back it's not even in the frigerator I
just
with a beer that's well that's true okay
all right recapping Tulsa plus eight and
a half
Missy State plus seven and a half
Wyoming Cowboys plus 14 Mizzou minus
seven blue lane the 23 and a half
SMU plus nineteen and a half NIU plus 14
that's college okay
NFL Vikings plus five and a half sling
blade - three Philly plus five and a
half all right and then you have the bet
with the front row the area 31 18 and a
half I'm layin 18 and a half army is
getting 18 and a half sold okay
Shea have a great weekend it's always
great to see you yeah all right whatever
all righty we'll come back we'll close
up shop after this in the Dan Patrick
show the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience